su t seven trovi un vero miraggio se ti
meravigli delle sue storie sei molto
saggio andiamo a sochi serve salpiamo
per ts even ora perché vado a
controllare dove ora che c'è la mia
ombra sopra il bar quanto figo c'è la
mia ombra della l'ombra club della nave
gigantesca poi vedo la mia ombra nel nel
mare
cadi cadi ponte sono sul si chiama
puzzle sull'altro albero sono
sull'albero una scimmia
non conosco si terminologie piratesche
io allora dobbiamo andare a tra l'altro
[Musica]
no no veramente descrivere puoi andare a
destra che stiamo andando impugnato
siamo andati lì dobbiamo andare per
cortesia
noi dovremo spegnere le luci perché
siamo molto più visibili così adc e al
posto di sopra farla scimmie potrebbe
anche scegliere io lo sto facendo la
scimmia sto guardando dove stiamo
andando sono stessi guardando io saremo
andando da non so dove si ma se noi non
tiriamo l'ancora porca vacca morta
meno male potevamo anche entrare lì è
roba che se quel posto di un nome così
come dai meglio così riusciamo a
domagnano a banana il suo mezzo morto
ok sull'isola cosa che c'è scritto
ancora il pappagallo dall'occhio rosso
sopra l'acqua interne a nord e ascolta
il mio consiglio leggere questa mappa
rivelerà un altro appiglio che che spara
yo yo fra le acque interne sopra quindi
vuol dire che di sopra di risalire
all'ora spettano al cui interno il
simbolo la luce
1 la bussola cura la lanterna 26 qua ho
perso e gli oled e di qua e là cui
interne dice al nord
ok ok ho capito latina lanterna amico
tim
non so chi sia ma c'è qualcuno che sta
scrivendo e il ha ben fatto sono sulla
nave l'ha scritto lui c'è un tizio sulla
nostra nave certezza sulla nostra ego
non team economy team e con un tipo
tranquillo e sicuro che con noi intesi
minchia che kagami madonna vedi perché
non vorrei mai fare le partite in sei
sono chiedo pubblico amico di fatto è
vero vai giudicherà le 20 10ª potute g13
complici
find the new haven
l'ultimo trova il racconto del
cacciatore sulla cengia erbosa cosa una
cento al nord ovest poi se il tizio ci
fotte la nave per ora conti il racconto
del calcio è questo il racconto del
calciatore
questo racconto del cacciatore fisico
esatto no no uno scheletro dietro di me
dietro invece nessuno ce n'è uno c'è
nulla addosso il figlio che cavalca la
parola ai atto mancato
bravo grazie missioni la corte ma magari
se scavi di più si no
così invece qua c'è qualcosa che
qualcosa ho trovato un tesoro e tesoro
oh mio dio
vai vai avere queste sta roba è una roba
oro mentre sono dorati simo forziere del
capitano via di qua veloci è come si
dice uno squadre aiuto di al tizio di
far elettro marcia sono fatto ma non
male di più a ciao
questo è il nostro compagno non so fossi
tu hey man luc de scheletri behind you
and i've got dei soldi se mi colpisce
per caso lo squalo che dietro sono morto
morto che cerchi e morale che mi fa non
mi ha colpito che culo
siamo ancorati di merda e dobbiamo
andare in retro va in retro metti la
retromarcia bel annuncia l'altro maggio
la barca ore quando soddisfacente per
destituire la colazione
però se ci arriviamo a non cantare
vittoria che ci possono sempre a saltare
dal momento alcuno ha detto cantare
no ti prego che poi si mette pure
l'altro a farlo ma dimmi che non lo fa
vi prego senza per 372 i due imbecilli
prego ti prego
speremo de no vi prego iddio 2
mongoloidi barca 2 mongolo e non ce n'è
uno che fa un cervello giustamente
guarda 2 deficienti
ma sai che ti dico ma si faccia morita
rosati di punti [ __ ] va e si dà
e vai
i beatles e venire un secondo ti
supplico ma per il forziere da vanità no
la prima barba si chiama barbara
marinaio marassi che la mamma mesiano
barbe parma grazie casi e o proponi
viaggio lecito bottino di mad oli di
qualche aspirante lupo di mare vai da
teco jack farlo che mister hyde sinistra
amico frank si ammira un po è tranquillo
fissato a maya dell'ancora poi offrono
soldi con cui è stato tra l'altro troppo
a sinistra amico destra destra
girai scherzo stavano preoccupato a fare
le cose ora in aia che mai
e vabbè sono qua ha già preso un
forziere vai giù barca vacca che voi ma
è solo sott'acqua io che chiuso ok
chiudo io con la già trovato il tesoro
in un secondo ma che è quelle c'è uomo
che è una voce a dirlo c'è una sola
entrata segretissima dopodiché segrete
belle prede davanti davanti a noi e se
stai andando dritto non potremo mai
entrarci loro rientro solis e magari vai
dritto a parte che comunque non so noi
dobbiamo la mappa è che allora visto che
siamo scesi può che oramai ha paura e
quando ci avviciniamo al tiro sulle vele
e faccio fa solo bene guarda un po più
avanti ma è questo il costo vice e ti
dirà ancora ci siamo però ancora fatto
tempo anche io che vai parte che i pezzi
di carta né nell'acqua non sismica non
puoi farlo risultato può fare corsi
d'acqua non bisognava sconto mediamente
pare che figo sto paure 15 giu qualche
vecchio porco rocca che vota sarà morto
io sono morto a sei morto anche tu
noi siamo in mano
mickey è che volte incredibile il nostro
amico dove sarà uscito dopo aver visto
star ho capito che sia qua si capiva che
sinistra guarda pirla consegnato trovato
io
secondo me qua a cagare largo gaetana
d'accesso ai giovani
chi giusto no ragazzi vi prego ve lo
chiedo per cortesia regga bene acqua
dove sono morti una buona cortesia me
fate quello che volete però per favore
no la musica per favore
c'è un amico bello che basta non c'è
male di testa
e va bene male dai facciamo tutti
insieme dai osanna e osanna e rosanna
cristo signor cosa ha fatto la sua
compagna parte suonare e saltare sulla
barca e nient'altro
però è l'unico tra tutti non è morto
siamo in mezzo al quale guarda camastra
cosa vedo sì ma mi sa che piove mi sa
che è un casino qua tira dirà di non è
una tiratina veloce lascia la cena certo
vado madonna della barca che ancora
madonna non è una donna che botta questo
è stata come siete messi sotto ma sai
che non si ammassino di male
penso che strano se dove ha reso la nave
devi salire sul tetto della del porto
va bene 54 il tuo attenzione dai primo a
sparare ai 415 no trovato da due dopo
qualche soldo in più ti compravi la la
ghironda del topo di sentina e che
sapeva girono è la chitarra 469 no
mancano mancano viene ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto come al solito servizi
sociali momento mi piace ricordategli
forzieri sono tutti i nostri però che vi
sia piaciuto cosa ci si siede ci vediamo
da ragazzi
[Musica]